elodie can finally give comfort to her
children
after walking for two days in torrential
rain to find
safety she had dashed from her home the
democratic republic of congo's northern
kivu region
after armed groups had descended on her
village
we had no food and we had no money to
pay for a vehicle
my children's feet were swollen and our
feet hurt where we were staying
we were rained on all the time and we
had nowhere to sleep
now we are settled this camp in beni is
becoming crowded
and the u.n refugee agency says it's
overstretched
the region has faced many emergencies
ongoing fighting with rebel groups in
two provinces in kivu and ituru
the after effect of gomer's mount
nirogonga's volcanic eruption in may
and the world food programme says nearly
7 million people in the region
are facing hunger we assist in emergency
so we provide
trouble in to idps who have recently
been displaced so that they can
themselves help build some emergency
shelter
elodie was just one of two million
people who had been pushed out of
northern kivu in the past two years
that's where more than a hundred armed
groups are operating
the provinces of north kivu and ituru in
the east of drc
were placed under military rule in may
to stop escalating violence which had
plagued this region for years
but it wasn't enough to prevent a rebel
attack in displacement camps and nearby
villages
a month later at least 14 people were
killed
more kidnapped and home scorched
now mass graves mark the area
many pushed east into this camp in benny
but people live in constant fear of
attacks and with
overcrowded tattered tents people such
as baccatura were moved into this local
school
but he says it's only a temporary
solution
as classes are resuming soon the
director may ask us to leave
my stay here is long overdue but i don't
know where to go next
people have attempted to return home
some say the violence has forced them
out
many times but the un says it's low on
funding and can't accommodate the sheer
volume of people
seeking help nor about a manly al
jazeera